[Music]
oh it seems so exciting I can talk to
anyone just begin the game and launch
into the Thunder
but 15 perverts later I still haven't
had the chance to talk to anyone but
that giant guy and woman's Underpants
it's the kind of instant judgement that
I fear in the real world where it only
takes a moment to realize you're not a
girl and they click on next the game's
over and the s I've lost again but I
keep on trying anyway because some days
[Music]
and I try to pull my heart out but they
keep clicking next
cuz I'm having a bad day on chatroulette
oh I'm having a bad day on chatroulette
[Music]
and suddenly this cute girl she pops up
on my screen she's like the answer to my
prayers blew a man of my dreams yes she
pauses on my face and I think she could
be mine I say hello she smiled got my
chance and then she hits
in her places a group of rowdy British
teams followed by a person who does not
wish to be seen and then a guy with
possum apps who won't put on his shirts
and then of course a very very long
string of perverts and I'll try to pull
my heart out but they keep clicking next
cuz I'm having a bad day on chatroulette
oh I'm having a bad day on chatroulette
the Prix girls are busy having pleasant
conversations with guys who've been
nesting for hours oh I really should
eliminate all my expectation fashion
also proudly take the shower but then
this guy comes on and he sees me playing
and he says he understands everything
I'm saying and he pulls down his guitar
he plays along
[Music]
we try to pull our hearts out but the
baby buggy next we're having a bad day
on chatroulette yes we're having of that
day on chatroulette
[Music]
just to be clear because the Internet is
what it is unfortunately
chatroulette is a place for adults and
I'm not gonna be on chatroulette so
don't go there looking for me because
you won't find me you will find things
that no one wants to see nonetheless I
hope that you enjoyed it thank you so
much to Tom Milsom Kristina Horner and
Luke Conard and of course thank you to
all the nerdfighters who submitted clips
of themselves looking bored when I asked
Twitter for those videos you should all
take this as an invitation when you
follow me on Twitter sometimes you get
to be in my music videos Kristina and
Luke who are in that video have a band
they're called all caps they have a new
album that just came out there's a link
to it in the sidebar
there's also alibi yeah and I'm also
gonna put up some links to a couple
music videos they did from that album so
that you can enjoy them John I will see
you on Friday
[Music]